E1 giving lines for example like Queen
to E7 Knight into B5 leaping in the
Knight again got has D6 a rook might
land on C7 lot of advantages here for
white nevertheless it's not so easy this
king is a little bit suspect because
this dark Square Bishop will remain on
the board for quite some time so has
Robson judged this so acutely so finely
that he thinks he still has enough
compensation to save the day well it
looks like for sure he's not winning
this position he's got to be thinking
about maybe drawing and Linderman has to
feel like hey I can really put my foot
on his neck and take the driver's seat
here in the Championships back to you
jenz wow three and a half out of four
would be no joke for Alexander Lenderman
not one of the tournament rating
favorites that would be huge and the
boldly stating the obvious his uh the
pre pre-tournament favorite and
defending Champion gakamsky
can't win a single game after three
rounds so if got could easily find his
title slipping away by just simply
drawing too many games and to start with
three and a half out of four is simply
huge huge uh something went wrong for
Ray there when he sacrificed The
Exchange I didn't think it was that bad
but try but playing for or rather
achieving the position he has on the
board right now that's a failure for for
The Rook sacrifice that's really bad
well you were mostly not looking at 95
which is logical because the lines that
you were looking at the Rooks weren't
open cuz the files were closed well
exactly that was like your instinct to
look for lines where it was a little bit
more closed and the minor pieces could
have a little bit of fun precisely just
to uh repeat uh What uh you're you you
you mean what what you're saying there
Jennifer is that when you sacrifice an
exchange which is fine I mean you can
sacrifice The Exchange in lots and lots
of positions you just don't want to open
up the game on lots of files because
your opponents has the Rooks and open
files are the ideal for Rooks so when Ry
went in for this uh trade he really
should not be trading pawns and
essentially he lost the C5 Pawn uh in
the line that I was looking at I was
kind of expecting that Ry was going to
play the position slowly and I had
talked about Knight A4 utilizing the
bishop keeping the position somewhat
closed and playing for B5 and A5 the
line I had mentioned instead um Ry went
for what for me was very
counterintuitive he traded the pawn on
D5 opening up the dile for The Rook for
the C5 PA Pawn there was this exchange
and now another Pawn disappears uh
Bishop takes F7 check uh King went back
into the corner and as uh Maurice was
mentioning well just bring your Rook to
the open file and suddenly both of
White's Rooks are
tremendous uh in this position and so I
think Rey is in deep trouble certainly
he better hope black had better hope
that he can generate some kind of
threats because otherwise he'll just
lose this game uh without a
shout that's right so a pretty
instructive lesson there on the uh the
power of the Rook so um we uh we have
some winners for our chess.com contest
so keep those question coming because
we're going to continue to give those
prizes out for the rest of the week so
the hash uschess Champs or you can use
comments at St Louis chess club.org
congratulations to Bill schaer and
Michael Mulford who won chess.com
memberships for their questions
submitted to comments at St Louis chess
club.org and also congrats to kids
Tristan Isaac Ethan and Dylan who win
gold memberships to chesskid.com a great
place for kids to go and learn the game
um and also a very safe and secure site
for online test play so keep your
questions coming and you know it makes
it a lot of fun small world uh when I
started playing chess in
1972 one of the players uh that was in
the Seattle chess scene was a guy by the
name of Michael Mulford so if it's the
same mic a shout out to say hello it's
been a while hey we'd love to hear from
you and we got some breaking news from
Grandmaster Ashley on another one of our
top rated players Alexander onuk hasn't
won a game yet but is this it is this it
this is gonna be it he is all over Sam
Shanklin right now I mean it looks like
it's all over but the crying right now
in this position look at this game it
was really quiet nothing much was going
on and it he played this nice Bishop to
B5 move and Sam decided to play this
move H6 which I didn't think was
anything the bishop could simply have
dropped back but onishchuk saw a fine
point here he said let me take and
weaken this piece here and then I'm just
going to take over the C file which
you'll never have ever again in life the
move Bishop to D3 was played now Rook to
C7 attacking the pawn and Sam decided to
jettison this Pawn with this move A5
figuring that this Pawn would just be
too weak to be able to ever push you
know what he said I don't need your Pawn
you can defend that one but let's get
back to this guy the weakness on G5 what
quick play what fine play and after Rook
a to B8 he said Munch First Pawn gone
and now this trade happened takes and
takes and then suddenly
bam second Pawn ripped off the board
this bishop cannot be accepted because
of the classic mating line after Rook
takes King over Rook check King over and
mate so now suddenly down two pawns is
Sam he played this move Bishop F Bishop
to C4 which will win back this Pawn but
it's not going to be enough because
after a bishop to F5 Rook takes B2 and
now the move H4 these white pieces are
swarming over the king and it's very
difficult to defend this position right
now if you try to push your own Pawn
here comes the move E6 just ripping that
King apart now of course A3 would lose
to takes on F7 you can't move your king
because of Rook mates and this is not
going to help because of Czech and again
if well you actually have to block and
now uh Bishop to E6 check and give us
the rook and mating ideas are coming all
over the place so this position is just
dead busted he's hanging on by his
fingernails is saying Sam Shanklin all
on the shuk has to do now is find the
right sequence and Sam is in deep
trouble back to you Jen and yes wow one
of the things I love about Chess is that
whether you're looking at Amer games or
the top players you deal with the same
Basics on some level a lot of times you
don't get to see that double Rook check
may actually occur but that's just what
we're teaching somebody who's learning
the game absolutely sure we saw that
earlier in the tournament right there
pattern recognition and these patterns
in chess are repeating time and time
again and I was just going to say this
this uh is what makes uh Alex onuk such
a formidable competitor here in these
championships uh he started the
tournament slowly but in his own view uh
solidly three draws but great
preparation by Alex once he's given an
opportunity he doesn't let it get away
um python like uh style uh he he he
manages the Garder a few couple of wins
and in a slowc scoring tournament he
must ha that Lenderman might go at three
and half out of four but in a slow
moving event he could be uh looking for
uh the title that's right this is a
right now I I'm agreeing with Maurice
completely this is a
smashing uh position and it's looking
really good for onuk and I just might
say from a different point of view a
very human a very human uh line of play
might be uh I I appreciate that Bishop
F5 is probably a superb move from a
human point of view it's it's nice to
play like this H5 that bishop6 remains
teed right it kind of like like remains
tethered and you start looking at uh
lines that go like this right where
where you take advantage of the fact
that the Bishop stance on E6 probably
Bishop F5 the computer move is stronger
but these are the type of lines that I'm
sure uh onuk is calculating more than
one way to win more perhaps more than
one way to win and H4 H5 H6 is kind of
to be a little careful because the pawn
on A4 is not that of course of course I
mean it may end up costing you a rook
like even here you know maybe King H7 is
looking for CU now I'm actually
threatening to take the rook and Bishop
takes F7 allows Rook takes F7 so are a
little a couple little tricky here and
there but I guess you were wanting to
point out that maybe 87 at the end of
that variation or something right but I
was also going that's kind of cool oh
would you like oh yeah you want to show
that okay so Bishop takes F7 Jennifer
there you got the the tactics girl but
um does this even work though oh no
because V8 you bet so there's always one
more you always got to look one more
move forward exactly I was thinking that
after this position by the way the kind
of Checkmate uh that Maurice uh so
instead of G7 Rook F6 continuing to the
pin right me keeping that Bishop taboo
exactly and this is one of our back rank
checkmates is about to appear here very
human way of um reeling the victory home
so to speak you're just trying to get
our viewers at home in shape with all
these 20 push-ups that they have to do
every time they see a back rank on the
board right there you go there you go
absolutely you both players definitely
into exercise as well as chess it's
always really important in fact
Alexander onuk is a triathlete so that's
how he keeps up with these youngsters
right by working really hard that's how
you do it right and by the way the next
to the chase hotel where all the players
are staying is really one of the most
beautiful parks in the whole of America
uh Forest Park and the players are
really going out and training and even
though they're there's some been some
very warm days here in St Louis they
love that Park and you'll see them
running and walking they do speed
walking and runs uh all over the place
it's great and keep your eyes open for a
men's health issue that's coming up
which has uh a little profile on some of
uh the importance of Chess and fitness
wonderful and we've got a Grandmaster
Ashley with uh some more of the exciting
action this
round well it's not a explosion
happening in this game but very
important development for the players
who would love to see gakamsky keep
drawing his his way stay sleepy and
don't win any games at all in these air
championships he is playing against
Sergey Arenberg and something
interesting happened after he started
with the trosi we have an original
position on the board he decided to open
up the game with the move E4 we know got
can play restrain chess but here he
tried to open up the game a bit with
this move E4 D takes E4 Knight takes E4
and aronburg probably surprise him with
Castle's Queens side this is not
something that you would expect to see
so so often after this Pawn has pushed
it looks a little Airy but it's actually
Houdini's First Choice it thinks this is
a great move that was played and now
castles and aronburg blew open the
position with the move E5 he actually
could have started with F5 and get some
pressure on the position but now E5 and
this is probably equal according to
Houdini it looks as though black is
going to be completely fine here uh if
you take on E5 then that runs into
Knight takes E5 take a look at that un a
discovered attack on the queen and then
it's just some simple stuff that's trade
off and put a queen in the middle like
this and white has no Advantage
whatsoever so kamsky can't be happy with
lines like this considering he's four
rounds in and hasn't won a game in the
championship yet I don't think he's done
that in a long while so we'll see how he
handles the rest and we're going to go
to commercial break we'll be back soon
here at the 2014 US chess championships
hi I'm Lindsay part of the admissions
team here at Paul mitel the school St
Louis our campus is located on Maryland
Plaza right here in the gorgeous Central
West
End I chose Paul Mitchell the School of
St Louis because I visited other schools
and when I was at them I just felt like
the energy level wasn't the same it
wasn't as elevated as it is
here when I came here it just felt right
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude the facility was
really clean and just so much more
advanced technology can truly enhance
your
education when we brought in Chromebooks
and we started using the smart TVs we
really tapped into the 21st century
learner being being a student of pal
Mitchell is great because the learning
leaders they're there to guide you in
the right direction they give you the
opportunity to make decisions on your
own they accept you for who you are and
they're always welcome and honest and
open we have encouraged our guests to
host Google reviews so far to date have
over 100 reviews with an average rating
of 4.5
Stars so I like that this isn't just for
hair and beauty but it's also a business
college
you can learn hair you can brush it you
can tease it you can learn all of that
but to do business that's something that
really takes a whole different level of
Education whether we're in the classroom
or at the color bar we're always having
a great time at Paul Mitchell the School
St
Louis being a student of Paul Mitchell
gives you a lot of opportunity for when
you're ready to get out into the real
world thank you for taking a sneak peek
of our campus and we can't wait for you
to come and see what a pal mitell
education can do for
you welcome back to the 2014 US Tess
championships and us women wins thank
you guys for your questions and comments
um we've got some good ones coming in um
Arena zenyuk um tweeted that she's
spending the free day at the St Louis
Art Festival oh nice so nice that uh
she's not just H up in a room studying
chess but enjoying all the culture and
art that St Louis has to offer which is
quite considerable by the way that's
right yeah wonderful
historical um buildings very near here
in the Central West End sorry and a
beautiful Zoo beautiful botanical
gardens just off the charts so um musio
log on Twitter and we've also got a a
question when do you tend to spend the
majority of your clock time how much of
it is influenced by your opponent's
speed and that's from Axel ammer that's
a good question I think the the point is
though that the top players in the
country and the world are the best at
that because time management is a
critical part of the game so um the
weaker the player the less they know
when to think right yeah well absolutely
one of the um comments that former world
champion Boris basy said in an in an
interview that really uh uh stuck with
me he you know went asked why he was the
world champion and he was first amongst
equals and such things and what
distinguished him from uh the other
great players of the time he said he had
a great sense for when was the critical
moment and when to use his clock that's
that was like profoundly interesting
right that he
sensed this is the moment that I have to
spend some time because this is the key
moment and his opponents didn't really
have such an acute sense and would spend
their time perhaps in the wrong position
so that really is a a good question and
um the difference in grandmas levels are
just small little key things and it was
something like that that really stuck
with me the sense of the critical moment
and to spend yes new inest very
interesting wow I like that and uh
another question we have uh Joseph donah
who asks how much of ky's drawn record
up to this point do you attribute to
people being extra conservative about
him against him well I don't say it's
extra conservative at the moment one of
the things that God is is running into
is really great preparation his
opponents are prepar are well well
prepared for him in particular that's
why you saw this kind of move the tromp
trompos move Bishop G5 trying to avoid
the Deep preparations that his opponents
have prepared at the same time when you
play a move like Bishop G5 I think
you're kind of giving up a lot of
White's opening advantage and Marice was
uh during our break there that we just
had uh Maurice and I were looking at uh
csky game against aronburg in some depth
and we were having a real hard time
finding a way for God to mix it up
because we think the position is really
even in this moment G uh did tried to
play the he did in fact play the move C5
we were looking at the queen dropping
back to the C7 Square Brave arur the
last time he Castle Queen side in this
tournament it's black bad things
happened
okay he doesn't let that get to half no
and we were looking at captures on E5
Knight captures C5 so again the material
equality is being kept and a key move
that Maurice pointed out as you do want
to get your king kind of safely tucked
in over here on the king side right and
it doesn't seem like either player has
much of an attack of course the key
difference in this position is that in
the last one there was actually a bishop
on G2 you know just raking through the
entire diagonal and massive issues here
it's just there's no Bishop it's just a
position where the Kings happen to be on
opposite sides right it usually that
indicates an attack but not when there's
so much simplification right and in this
position is very easy to see that the
open defile black is very happy uh he'll
put his Bishop on the uh Italian
diagonal looking at whites King the the
the defiles a chopping block and Maurice
and I are sitting there going wow when
is G going to get get into stride and
defend his title because if he just
keeps drawing uh and we're seeing um
Lenderman having success after
success um wow uh this title this
championship and got his title are going
to slip away that's right it is luckily
for him an 11 round tournament so he
still has time to kind of get his Groove
but he better get it pretty soon exactly
time is ticking totally balanced I think
I mean that Queen on' 4 is a strong
piece but at the same time that Bishop
on C5 you got to in this particular
position it seems to be working harder
than the KN on F3 so exactly like for
instance even E6 move we a lot of times
we're going to have to worry about a
queen takes g3 at the end of the
variation indeed maybe immediately a
queen takes G3 thanks to this bishop on
C5 the F2 Pawns in an absolute pin and
you've got to be concerned that uh you
might blunder your G3 Pawn if you're not
looking carefully enough right so just
keeping the balance here aronburg right
and uh one more question I wanted to
point out because we have this beautiful
view right here in the webcam um we have
a question from Ryan harmeson harmson um
and he
asked um about The Talented youth that
we have in America what do you feel like
is necessary in order to have a US
player as a top contender in the years
to come well we do already have one top
Contender that's hiara Nakamura
absolutely how do we make more Nakamura
and maybe even get another couple
players in that top 10 now we should
also point out that Fabiano Karana did
start his chess career in America we can
kind of half claim him he's an American
citizen but he does play for Italy
officially right exactly and I think
that uh really like wonderful plants you
need fertile fertile soil so you
need uh cities like St Louis chess clubs
like St Louis competitions like the US
championships that encourage generations
of youngsters to put down the basketball
and pick up uh the chess KN that they
might get a reward at the end of the
rainbow exactly and one of and to that
question by the way one of the things I
think is really been fantastic for
American American chess is unlike any
other time that I can ever think of in
my whole chess career universities and
colleges are giving scholarships to
build chess players for example here in
St Louis you have the Lindenwood
University chess team as well as
Websters where yeah Ray Robson goes to
Webster University Ray yes and so the
recognition that colleges and
universities are giving to chess is
marvelous that has serious Rippling
effects way down the line right that's
absolutely true this is the best time I
think for Tess America that I've seen of
course um people say that the Fisher era
was was awesome
it was a yeah it was a the the Fisher
boom really really really was a kind of
an elite type of deal where you really
got players wanting to become world
champions um but what's happening today
is you're getting uh the numbers are
getting bigger and bigger and bigger if
you go to the supernationals for example
you'll see 5,000 competitors at the
supernatural naal that happens every
four years and you actually have over
2,000 which was a record 2200 Plus in
Jesse Elementary Nationals um another
thing we should mention is the Casper of
young Stars program which is the KCF St
Louis chess club program you've also got
the shine Freedman camps that was
started by Mark Chine and a fredman yes
um and they bring great chess camps to
encourage our top youth also my brother
started the US chess school and the US
chess League too that's right and the US
chess school is going to have a session
actually coming up in St Louis with all
of the top girls in the country
fantastic I'm going to be doing that one
with Greg so and those chess camps by
the way um not I'm not going to say
they're a recent phenomenon because
they've been around uh quite a number of
years but on the other hand there's been
an explosion of the numbers of Chess
camps as well as the number of students
who are who are at the camps and the
number of elite ones these are just
chests that are open to everyone this is
open to kids who show that they've got
what it takes right and we've got a a
comment from uh Grandmaster Ashley
well just wanted to jump to a game which
may be the first victory of the day
we're predicting from the game onishchuk
versus Shanklin and Onish shuk in this
position after having his Pawn captured
on B2 decided to play not Bishop F5 but
the move Bishop to D7 controlling the
pawn on A4 Pawn on A5 from going to A4
and getting ready to Ram his Pawn down
champlin's champlin's throat get that
out right shanklin's throat with the
move E6 now if that is stopped with the
move Rook to E2 then onu is prepared to
make a pawn storm dominant position on
this side he's about to play the move F5
if you try to to attack some pawns
forget it it's just all going to be
pawns everywhere F6 and then this move
E6 and this position is just ugly after
takes check of course that pawn was
looking to go to E7 and grab yet another
pawn and the position is just ridiculous
A Move Like Bishop to D3 uh trying to
chase The Rook out wouldn't help because
of this and Rook G8 is coming and it's
just really horrible it looks as though
Shanklin will not be able to even Stave
off immediate defeat it looks so bad
right now it's up to it's up to Onish in
this moment and it looks like it has
happened actually Rook E2 has happened
and all he has to do is play F4 and
instead he's played E6 immediately not
the most dominating move certainly a
good one as well let's back that up to
the moment here he did play Rook to
E2 here and E6 was played this is
definitely a good move but the computer
is not as impressed by this move and it
thinks that after A4 black has some
fighting chances so interesting
development here F4 would have just been
dominant F4 F5 and go all the way home
instead he's played A4 and seems to
sorry E6 and seems to have given his
opponent a chance with this move A4
still winning for him uh after Rook to
A7 so we know Onish shuk is the kind of
guy who likes to play control chess
guess he didn't want to go into those
wide lines he has but F4 F5 F6 look F6
looked really really good what do you
think well this is the old problem with
chest that sometimes you have an
embarrassment of riches uh definitely a
dominating position for Alex onuk uh
wide Choice F4 F5 very natural to get
that pawn storm going but the strangest
thing is I was looking at the mediate E5
E6 as well because of that um uh
Checkmate that you had pointed out the
classical uh Rooks on the on the you
call the name up for us yeah oh for sure
let me just bring that uh game too many
good moves like too many too many party
invitations as absolutely absolutely let
me get that one up on our screen um Happ
before and just to show the the the line
that we were talking about again uh
Maurice was pointing out that F4 F5 F6
that was really going to be uh to be a
decisive continuation for white but I
too like this move E5 E6 because I was
attracted to the same Checkmate that
Maurice had been showing earlier which
was that white pardon me black could not
capture the pawn thanks to the classic
double Rooks nice little smother made if
that Rook was not on f8 this would not
be Checkmate this yes if this Rook were
the the king would have a square but
this was the Checkmate that every chess
player is familiar with uh experienced
chess player it's a pattern we all like
to to execute execute and so that was
why the move E5 E6 I found attractive no
doubts that the move a
um
A5 A4 I I know my squares I can get that
out A4 is Black's best and then one line
if there was a lot of trading going on
for example captures
check
check captures captures it looks like
White's a nice healthy two pawns to the
good but at the end of this line there's
this little nasty Rook to E4 with uh the
idea of winning one of the pawns that
he's behind back and Sam can definitely
fight from this position this isn't uh
an easy win by any stretch of the
imagination so it may turn out
unfortunately that the attractive
looking move E5 E6 was not White's best
in that position and that just going F4
F5 was in
fact the right way to proceed so the
best looking move is not always the best
one yeah that what's really strange is
sometimes the most the very most natural
move in the position developing a piece
or doing something that everybody would
would do turns out to be wrong that's
that that's really the confounding one
that's that that's where Grand Masters
just shake their head and say
something's wrong with the rules of
chess the laws uh get turned upside down
well usually though that intuition that
you develop does work so it's absolutely
it's very and they're very rare of
course and we have nitzki vers Ramirez
um we we got the pleasure to speak to
Tel nitz's mom just a little bit earlier
with the show okay and how's he doing in
his position against it's been a while
RZ let's take a lookz coming off a tough
loss from yesterday where again he was
outgunned in the opening in that game
and Maurice has been very generous in
his praise uh for Daniel's um approach
to this game uh let's just go back a few
more moves because this move Knight C4
this is a very unusual construction with
the double Knights on C3 and C4 you take
that C2 Pawn however and you put it on
C5 and it's better it's it's a thing of
beauty actually with the pawn on C2 the
double Knights looks kind of funny
that's why you don't play one E4 that
much right well if I could get these
positions I might I'd take it up okay so
Knight B6 was tra was played and after
the trade um uh Alejandra took a
long
um uh it's a he made the decision to
take with the pawn and in the long term
that could those double pawns on B7 and
B6 could come back to haunt him so in a
sense what we're talking about critical
positions that was a very important
recapture uh the game continued Bishop
B2 castles Bishop D3 all very natural
moves from both sides finally we see
black connecting his Rooks with the move
Bishop D7 so by your definition this is
the beginning of the middle game correct
and it makes it very easy to understand
the three phases of the game
uh Bishop D6 Bishop D7 pardon me to go
to C6 to try to activate the bishop
Knight E4 white opens up the long
diagonal for his own Bishop that we see
a
trade
takat let's just see uh the the battery
thanks to the support of the bishop and
there are three main ways to stop this
um it looks like black chose F5 and uh
um let's invite uh Grandmaster Ashley
into this convers
abolutely who do we like here well I
hate the fact that the knights are off
the board first of all because now
everything is about linear pieces but I
do like the fact for white that all
those weaknesses are in the position
look at those weaknesses on B6 B7 and
particularly now the new one the fresh
one on E6 we talk about the principle of
two weaknesses dorety made this idea
popular the idea being that you may your
opponent may have one weakness it may
not be enough to win the game but a
secondary weakness will allow you to
stretch your opponent's defenses now in
this case the weaknesses are pretty
close they're not that far apart but
still it looks like white has no real
issues at all in his position I mean at
all while black has to be concerned
about those weak pawns and and that
Bishop on the long diagonal and and then
other things coming Rooks of the open FS
as
well well I think it was a product of
necessity though because if we had
played G6 then perhaps our dark squares
would be irreparably weak yeah but
that's a bad sign if you got to start
making more weaknesses because of M
threats the guy's going to start milking
you and I think maybe he can hold here
with precise moves but if I see this
position I'm taking white nine times out
of 10 or well probably 10 out of 10 and
and uh trying to hold on for dear life
if I had the black pieces I would be
feeling like I'm going to lose if I
playing Yas for example with the with
the black pieces I would think someday
I'm going to lose this game it's no no
no uh the move F7 F5 another very
critical decision very easy uh this is
the type of game you can lose as black
without necessarily making any further
mistakes uh from this point onwards it's
like white has a lot of pluses in the
position so if black Alejandro is going
to save this game he can't mess around
he can't he doesn't have any luxury here
whereas Daniel has a lot of choices here
the first question Daniel really has to
ask himself is would he like to force
the trade of Queens which he could with
the move Queen E5 because of the threat
of check made on G7 so the first
question Daniel's got to ask himself is
it better to better to play the middle
game with the Queens on the board or off
the board if he decides it's better to
play with the Queens on the board he'll
likely step back with this queen keep
eyeballing this weakness on E6 which is
Maurice as just mentioned is a new uh
weakness in the position now he would
like to play Bishop C4 perhaps in some
moment so probably black will prevent
that by sticking and work on C8 right uh
we talk about the drawback of the move
F5 the the the move F5 does have one
positive thing going for him first of
all it gains a Tempo and in case of the
queen dropping back we do have this move
Bishop D6 picking up a second tempo if
White stops to uh keep his Pawn uh his
H2 Pawn protected with the move H3 then
at least with the pawns on E5 and F5
black is going to get some uh
counterplay for sure in this position
and that was why I was questioning
whether or not Daniel may want to play
Queen E5 let's see it seems like they
have played a couple of moves you want
to refresh and see if we you've got any
decision there um it's very important
when you have a decision about whether
or not to trade Queens because yes that
can really drive the game in a very
different direction I see people when
you're talking about sensing the
critical moment how do great players do
it well I think they develop it through
a lot of intuition but there's also like
some concrete things if there's a queen
trade on the menu it's a good sign
that's something you should think about
right well first of all uh you calculate
the for forcing lines first right and if
you can calculate your your way to a
clear Advantage well bang you don't even
go any further than that uh but if you
if the position is really
flexible and you have to find some
subtle and Quiet Moves that's a
different one that's where really just
study practice uh is going to develop
what you call your intuition but really
as we know it's the recognition of it's
pattern recognition from study uh by the
way Daniel did uh offer a trade of
Queens but he wanted to do it on
different terms You' mentioned that
you'd like to bring that Bishop to the
C4 Square so you could eyeball the E6
Pawn so he offered the trade of Queens
with Queen C4 uh Alejandra declined to
bring White's Bishop to the C4 Square uh
Daniel stepped back with his Queen to B3
keeping pressure on this E6 Pawn we have
seen King h8 in order to release the
pawn from a pin and Rook D1 bringing the
Rook to the open file Bishop D6 a move I
mentioned a moment ago attacking H Pawn
and I think we're up to date here I am
anticipating that Daniel will probably
play H2
H3 and Alejandro um is stuck I think
here this is just a a nice position for
white that's right so nitzki with an
advantage ownership with an advantage
Lenderman with an advantage lots to be
excited about today at the championship
where it looks like perhaps the men or
the participants in the US Chess
Championship are taking over for the
women and creating lots of decisive
results today well we all hope so I mean
uh we've had three rounds of 18 games
six round six games per round and of the
18 games played in the first three
rounds we've seen some really pitch
battles but only four decisive games so
a very low percentage of decisive games
plenty of and plenty of excitement
exactly but here's the point I kind of
expected that because I feel that this
is one of the strongest if not the
strongest us Championship ever to be
held an an all grandmas field very very
very tough competitors great res
resourceful players so lots of talent
indeed wow yeah the best and we've got a
quick thought from uh Grandmaster
Ashley indeed Jen it looks as though
onos shook has made his life much more
difficult ult than he needed to we saw
this position where it looked as though
F4 was tremendous right now if he had
played it he would have had a dominating
position just pushing his Pawn down the
board was easy no problem he had
different ways to win as a matter of
fact Bishop F5 was another one instead
here he chose the move E6 and the
resourceful Sam Shanklin found the move
A4 creating his own problem here to
deflect this bishop away and now onuk
made a move that was suboptimal he
played the move Rook to E5 trying to
force his Pawn forward and in this
position after a trade takes Sam got rid
of this Pawn on E6 and now Bishop takes
E6 check and King to H7 and they're on
this move right now after Rook to A7
this position the computer is saying
yeah you're up a pawn but it's kind of
funny it's not that dominant roller we
saw a second ago where there was
absolutely no counterplay now Onish shuk
loves positions like these these are the
kind of positions where he excels
technical dry no chances for the
opponent so maybe he felt very
comfortable going into this line he's
definitely still better maybe even close
to winning but it's a much harder task
he said himself when we come back from
the break we'll see if he can do what he
needs to to win this game and get in the
driver's seat here in the US
Championship back after this well
actually we've got something for you
during the break we've got another
puzzle I was about to say so I'm anxious
to solve one don't rest too much bis
guire Fisher
1967 black to move again poor bis guire
we're really beating up with him this
time okay he deserve it deserves
it
yeah
oh
you
e
he
yeah
welcome back to the 2014 US chess
championships we do have our first
result of the round well actually we
have two results but our first decisive
result of the round so Alexander onuk
has defeated Sam chlin all right um but
the puzzle the puzzle did you get it
first we got the puzzle um Bobby Fisher
in this position against bis guire so
we've been beating up on bis chire today
um Bishop played Bishop takes E4 nice
Bishop sacrifice after the bishop
captures on e4 King A4 and Black's just
going to come in with all the pawns
right exactly so kind of brutal and took
another six moves until bis guire
resigned this position our other result
that we have in um frell's game was a
draw against a koban right but right now
we actually have Grandmaster Sam
Shanklin and he graciously came down
after his defeat to talk with marce
Ashley Thanks Jen we are with grandm Sam
Shanklin uh he looked at the puzzle and
in about half a second he said I assume
his Bishop takes E4 right so he still
has his skills uh sorry for the loss
thanks for joining us however oh yeah
sure my so what went wrong this game oh
I felt kind of like a monkey I um I
prepared this line and just saw after
Bishop G6 the computer said equal and
just kind of like an idiot just pressed
the space bar and put the bishop on E2
and he played Bishop B5 which I hadn't
checked because it probably wasn't the
computer's First Choice and then I just
started calculating and somehow I got
the sense I'm just much worse and so I
felt like I I kind of was just the idiot
pressing buttons and not actually a guy
playing real chess so
I probably H6 was a very poor decision
um after he took on D7 and
hg5 and I'm not I think what I missed
was I miscounted Tempe after Rook fc1 I
thought I could play Rook F to B hold on
let's let's get that since our audience
is
uh game about I think it's yeah okay so
move 86 was yeah that was just an
atrocious move I thought Bishop E7 was
nothing after Rook fc8 but Bishop takes
D7 is just massively strong and yeah
after HG I just somehow missed that I
have just no way to contest the C file
like his Bishop's trapped on D7 but it
doesn't matter he's just going to put a
rook on C7 and I and we did see that
happen in the game um it looked like you
had a chance at some point later like he
may not have played it as strongest well
at this point here I just uh put my head
in my hands and started calculating I
decided any kind of sort of just put the
pawns on A6 and B5 and hope he can't
break through wasn't going to work so I
tried to make some kind of counterplay I
thought Bishop D3 was clever I threaten
Bishop C4 which will clog the C file for
one move so I can play Rook d8 and then
I'll be okay so he has after Bishop D3
He has to play Rook C7 and I'd
calculated this entire line with A5 he
can't take B7 and Rook A3 bishop and
Rook G3 but I had missed a takes B5 in
my
calculations so you're saying after you
play B5 here I just I complet when I
calculated this at when I played Bishop
D3 I missed a takes B5 which just
finishes me I'd only considered Bishop
takes E6 and then after B takes A4 it's
massively unclear um because then I
would be playing A3 and be queening some
pawns but here there's just no game to
be played indeed so uh a tough loss I
mean you did have the black pieces
against one of the best players in the
competition how do you bounce back now
well only in the US Championship Ron
Robin can you lose a game and then get
csky the next day so uh no I mean I'll
have white against campi it'll be my
second white of the events and my first
White went pretty well even though I
failed to to execute so um yeah I mean
it was very tough to start with three
blacks but um yeah it's it's a long
tournament and uh it's not by any
stretch over nobody's really grabbing
such a commanding lead I guess lerman's
really un formed but uh it's it's a long
event and you just have to you gulp it
down and play the next one indeed well
right attitude thanks for graciously
joining us Grand Master Sam Shanklin we
wish you the best in the rest of your
games yeah thank
you all right tough loss in the second
in the second loss is the second first
loss of the event are we still on yeah
we are okay it's your first loss yeah my
first Los of but he he'll be back to go
after ksky in uh the next round no no
easy games here at the US chess
championships back to you Jen and yes
yeah he'll be back as long as we don't
keep adding losses to his record exactly
well it's a very uh you get a very sour
taste in your mouth when you lose a game
literally from the opening because all
of those moves up to H7
H6 um have likely been played before in
a bad misjudgment there in terms of the
uh ending uh by Sam not recognizing the
fact that the bishop on D7 is actually a
monster Bishop not a prisoner uh but
rather doing very very effective work uh
the other game we had was between the
other result pardon me that we had was
between Josh fredel and VAR copian and
you thought that was a little
disappointing from a from a cobian's
point of view didn't you because you
liked his position he was y right and I
was speaking with him I was speaking
with both during the break and both
players um agreed that the position was
balanced at the time that a draw was
agreed um and Josh was very pleased with
himself because he had chosen a defense
that he had never played before it
worked out like a charm and VAR was
bitter because he had spent quite uh
some time with his second uh Gabriel
sarisan preparing this game and one of
the things they didn't look at was the
defense that Josh chose so that's it's
funny that you describe VAR as bitter
because I I just think AAR is always
having a smile on his face it's true
imagine really bitter right but strong
but he he was like disappointed point
out here well that's the value of
surprise and as we mentioned earlier
Grandmaster Josh fella has a
surprisingly strong record against a
higher rated of player than him vovan
right so just one of those interesting
matchups where he's won more games and
he's lost and here comfortable draw with
black so a good opponent for him and
maybe he'll bounce back now hopefully
because VAR uh has gone four draws now
he hasn't got he hasn't found a position
that he really enjoys playing and yet he
comes into this event as one of the
highest rated players speaking of high
rated players uh one of the
pre-tournament favorites Alexandra onuk
is in our studio waiting to be
interviewed uh by Maurice
Ashley thanks y I am with Grandmaster
Alexander onishchuk after his first win
of the competition welcome to the show
Alex thank you well you've been
methodical so far but this time you put
uh the hammer down to get a victory did
did you think you surprised him in the
opening when you played this move Bishop
to B5 uh well first of all uh I think
first of all he surprised me with his
opening choice because uh lately he
always plays the Greenfield and today he
played the the slav and um uh I didn't
play Queen E2 that that often maybe just
one game uh usually I play Knight H4 so
we kind of we surprising each other and
um uh yeah I mean I I couldn't remember
the Theory I I thought that actually
Bishop G6 is not the best move maybe
Knight B8 right away was was more
precise but I I couldn't quite remember
so Bishop G6 Bishop B5 and frankly I
thought during the game I thought that
I'm I'm already much better because if
um so what his choices here uh Knight B6
or Knight B8 right well also H6 the move
he played yeah if Knight B6 then then I
can uh simply play this move and if uh
let's say A6 then I go
A5 and during the game I thought that I
have a very good Advantage here a takes
B5 a takes B6 and then then I go Rook A7
at some point and uh I can bring my
Bishop to D6 or C5 I mean it's uh looks
like it's a very unpleasant position for
him right the computers agreeing with
you dominant uh position so it looked
like he was just in trouble really early
on after this bishop to B5 move he
looked he looked in terrific trouble and
then you got this tremendous position
later when you were able to take on E6
did your eyes light up when you saw you
could grab on E6 well I mean yeah sure
well actually I saw this idea right away
I think uh uh when did I see this idea
maybe almost when when he played H6 I
already saw this idea really yeah I
thought for like 10 15 minutes because
this was a very important moment I had
some some other choices too so once I
played Bishop D7 I I pretty much saw
this idea with Rook G3 and Bishop E6 as
well wow excellent and and then it it
seemed as if you had some easier ways to
knock him out you kind of let him ad
just a little bit of a chance yeah
honestly uh in this position uh he
played Bishop C4 yeah I thought that
this move is probably the most precise
one and after B2 I should play
E6 but somehow I didn't see how I went
after this this move and um I don't know
I I can play H4 and then he goes H4 and
I was a little bit nervous about the p a
pawn well that's exactly the second
round remember couple small technical
problems there but
um we were
just we were just talking about how
interesting it was that uh onuk said
that uh he saw all of this sacrificing
double Rook check made after H6 just
after Black Blade H6 he saw uh quite
deeply into the position and uh he
apparently saw
the the whole line that the that the
game went very early and it just seems
that uh Alex is dead on when he said
that the move Bishop G6 was just simply
mistimed and this move Bishop B5 just
throws the monkey wrench into Black's
position and he played very good chest
to that's right to uh lasso the point
and I think we have them back on with
our mic so we'll finish up that
interview well let's go back to Maurice
right sorry for those technical
difficulties Alex Alex say Mike fell off
you got all excited trying to show moves
there uh but um so in this position you
you you had that you had ghost the ghost
of the past Aon that happened in round
two it's funny how those things kind of
affect games later in the competition
that's why I played the bishop D7 to
stop A4 and yet he played the A4
anyways I have to deal with this a
again anyway okay so now you've uh you
got your win you're you're plus one
you're still chasing the leader
Alexander Lenderman how do you get ready
for tomorrow's game well tomorrow I play
with uh Jos fredom right uh well I'll
just play another game look it's still
seven rounds uh I have more blacks of
course but um you know I I I I think the
tournament has just started it's it's a
long tournament and um
uh it's it's very nice to win a game
because it's it's so so hard to win a
game in this tournament you know I like
in round two I thought I'm I I had a
winning position almost winning position
but and more time but my opponent played
just all brilliant moves all best moves
yeah so so yeah I'll I'll just prepare
like like like usual let me ask you two
more questions do you feel like this
tournament is the strongest us
Championship you've ever played in with
with only Grand Masters is that a you
have that sense that it's it's actually
tougher than the others yeah probably
maybe we don't have a big favorites here
like G used to be big favorite a few
years ago and also hikaro but uh yeah I
I I think I I have the sense that uh
this is probably the the most solid
tournament us Championship I've ever
played and and finally you're a
triathlete uh you say that there's 11
rounds is long versus nine rounds what's
the difference between a nine round and
11 round are the only two rounds I I
think I'm one of the oldest players here
but uh I think uh having more rounds is
in my favor because I I like I remember
last year with each round I I felt
stronger and stronger and same is here
so I hope to to play even better towards
the end indeed picking up team Alexander
onuk we wish you the best in the rest of
the tournament thank you Mar Grandmaster
and triathlete feeling good about
himself this it's just started he said
it just started four rounds in uh with a
win is Alex and trying to crawl up that
leaderboard back to you Jen and yes so
the longer the tournament the more
chances he has to win so could just make
it a double Round Rob man be here all
month well nothing like a victory to put
the wind in your saes and make you look
forward to the next rounds of the the
tournament really it's night and day and
chess really I mean we like to think of
it as a game of skill pure skill but
it's also really a game of confidence
and the greater your confidence the
better you feel about your play and you
you make your decisions a lot more
quickly rather than double guessing you
lose a game and suddenly the next thing
you know you're spending a lot of time
on your clock analyzing so Alex uh Happy
very very happy to get this Victory
under his belt very interesting and it
was interesting how um on also said I
did you see a little bit of a dig it got
a he said there's no clear favorite this
year yes I worries a little bit but um
let's go see if our our tournament
leader
Lenderman um has uh finished the job
against Ray Robson all
right and I think uh perhaps he was also
referring to the fact that Nakamura had
hasn't played the last few years and
that the other players were getting
stronger so I don't think he was
necessarily trying to disc adak Kansky
but it it does kind of show that we
might have a very tight tournament here
and that the top players think that it's
not just us hyping it up absolutely and
again you know we do have a junior
player in the field often times the
junior was kind of like a uh a Target
but Daniel niski is is not an easy
target at all so I see a very very
balanced field we're looking at the
that's right and you know it was
interesting at onishi's word choice he
didn't say he was a little reluctant to
say strongest but he said the most solid
right there's balance without without
Nakamura maybe he was a little tentative
to say strongest but the fact is there's
no weekies there's no easy day there's
nobody to Target as you were saying fair
enough until we maybe later in the
tournament there'll be somebody who has
an awful result and people will gather
around him like vultures exactly sharks
in the water they smell blood uh I
wasn't just so clear to me how or why
Sam actually uh gave up in the final
position so if you don't mind I just
brought up that game the finish of the
game between Oni Shook and uh Sam
Shanklin uh we went to this position we
left it at this position rookie five uh
Maurice was saying there's still some
troubles some difficulties for uh Onish
shuk to rope in the victory
uh there is this pass Pawn over here on
the a file that has to be dealt with and
that was dealt with right away with this
move Rook A7 getting behind the pass
Pawn threatening it with
capture uh Sam came up with this king
king G6 so what Sam's anticipating is
that as soon as white captures this Pawn
he's got this Rook E8 so he could
recapture this Pawn on
E5 that didn't take place instead after
King G6 uh onuk found a very nice move
G4 setting up for Bishop F5 check as
follow followed by the victory of the
win of the pawn Rook takes A4 King
stepped aside with King H6 Bishop went
back to F7 and suddenly oh my this is a
real problem now for black because
there's simply no way for him to deal
with this runaway criminal this pass
Pawn on E5 is going e E6 E7 and thanks
to this bishop controlling the promotion
square that was where Sam threw in the
towel and uh a good good moment to stop
the game um as we mentioned earlier aobi
and fale was a draw so we see that uh
position getting set up there it's funny
how Ferell was playing right next to his
picture today oh really in the
background it's funny how it sometimes
occasionally will match up very nice uh
if you don't mind I'd love to go to our
leader board our leader in the
tournament uh Grandmaster Alex
Lenderman he uh when we had left it he
was exchange up appearing to be cruising
to Victory let's see what the current
position is and we're going to go back
just to where we had left it when we had
left it uh we were about these parts uh
Knight C4 had been played Bishop G4
attacking White's Rook on
F1 the bishop The Rook moved away Rook
F1 also by the way protecting the bishop
on F7 like to keep the keep the pieces
nice and tight and uh coordinated Knight
D7 Queen A3 naturally when you're aead
material we tell this time after time on
all of our summer camps trade when
you're head material whites up a pawn
and an exchange he seeks to trade Queens
Bishop H3 Rook F2 B5 the queen trade was
executed Knight E5 a very nice tactical
shot uh there's a discovered attack
against the Knight on C5 so a tactic to
uh to trade basically right Bishop takes
Rook takes would be would be fine for
white would be great for white yeah
really would make life easier so Ray is
doing his best to keep as many pieces on
the board as he possibly can sure he's
down on materials he wants to keep
things complicated another thing you
teach it some my gamps I'm sure exactly
Knight E4 Rook F4 Bishop F5 and let me
get it so now the Knight on E5 is in
take and if the Knight on E5 moves then
the uh Bishop on F7 is loose so how does
white tactically get out of this little
Jam Bishop D5 doesn't seem to quite work
because then Bishop takes E5 well
there's an issue here with Knight takes
G6 the problem with Knight take you
would like to recapture with the pawn
and not to trade any more pieces but the
problem is this Bishop on F7 hems in the
King on uh h8 so you can't go King to G8
against a rook check so now Bishop H6
would be required right and now here I
think I have this nasty retreating move
gaining a Tempo move two black pieces
are in capture and one of them is going
to leave the board that's a sweet move
so if by contrast you play wait so if
you play Rook takes H6 check in that
position then just King G7 yes so the
immediate capture would allow indeed
allow this move King G7 when there are
two white pieces under uh capture and
for example after a rook Retreat uh
black could struggle on but let's go
back to this situation I'm anticipating
that you can't that uh Ray will have
he's mentioning Maurice Ashley is
mentioning a possible idea that after
Bishop D5 King G7 oh okay so once again
takes check Bishop H6
Bishop D5 attacking this Knight
attacking this bishop so the idea is I
guess G5 if uh Bishop takes E4 you have
a
G5 no there's a rook C7 check Rook C7
Jack yeah that's a nasty oh then the
King has to give up the protection
ofstead capturing on on E yeah right you
just you get in that and that's winning
that's just that's a stone cold win so
let's just let me see what has been
played uh just a moment I will bring
I'll refresh my board for a second so
this Knight takes G6 is
what that's the crucial move that's
that's the key move and lend is he's
raising his arm he is about to make a
move he's always got that green juice
next to him I guess that's his Elixir
where Carlson's got his orange juice and
Lenderman has his his his green juice
which uh is uh kind of an acquired taste
right what's in the green juice all
sorts of good things spinach pears
Everything Green oh very nice parsley by
the way Knight takes G6 exed okay okay
this was what uh we got Maurice joining
the conversation here what do you think
Maurice well London being playing like a
genius that's what I think I mean he
looks like he should be US champion
right now too bad you can't Cur him
after only four rounds but he's playing
some beautiful moves in this position as
we saw he did find the Fantastic
sacrifice Knight takes and after H takes
on G6 Rook H4 check Ray thought he had
him tricked with this move Bishop to H6
in fact yes you would have been tricked
with Bishop D5 if you played it because
Knight to F6 a very sneaky retreating
move saving the Knight and attacking the
bishop and now Rook takes on H six
doesn't do anything anything because of
King to G7 and you can't save that
Bishop so that move was not the key one
in fact the right move here after Rook
H4 check Bishop H6 is what the youngster
played Rook to C7 Thon seeing that this
bishop is dead to the world the king as
you pointed out can't come help because
of a nasty Discovery so it seems like
Lenderman has found just the right way
to play and in fact this line line is
worse for Ray than the other line of
taking on Bishop takes G6 uh so it looks
like lindaman is starting to drive uh
the pony's home right now wow well we
thought that
uh that if Lenderman were to win this
game at three and a
half uh points out of four he's doing a
demolition job while so many of his
Rivals nearest Rivals are having a tough
time winning an even in a single game so
you're right you you can't coronate him
this early after round four but he's
definitely in form top form that's right
and uh let's take a look and see about
got hamsky game against Sergey aronburg
because earlier you thought it was
really balanced but it seems like
perhaps the game is getting to be a
little bit more interesting than we
might thought oh wow you thought there
might be a lot of Trades and that
perhaps we would see even an ear earlier
handshake but
instead God has got something
interesting going well well something
happened very different from what
Maurice and I had been looking at we had
anticipated Queen C7 uh we didn't take a
look at this move Queen C3 we were more
concentrated I must say uh in our
analysis we were looking we were
calculating more forcing lines with
captures Queen C3 was G's move to try to
keep as much tension in the position as
possible and I'm not sure I like the
decision that Sergey played here he came
came up with F7
F5
um my first instinct is to say that this
was more of a critical moment and that
Sergey may have errored with this move
uh F5 but so the idea is that if taking
on D4 after Queen takes D4 that Rook on
h8 is hanging but uh yeah after takes on
D4 after takes on D4 takes on D4 you're
right the Rook on h8 is indeed hanging
um after Rook G8 with uh the counter
punch of Bishop G7 or possibly Knight
takes C5 white might have been worried
that he had overextended overplayed his
hand not sure well you could play you
could still play Knight D6 check was
similar to what happened in the game
yeah like after Knight D6 check for
example King over I guess you got a take
on F7 because otherwise Knight C5 is
really undermining you I was just I was
just thinking well you could play what
about B4 oh I'm sorry let's just see
that it might Tak F7 looks like a move
to analyze first cuz it's more for
saying exactly I was but B4 is is a move
and okay but then Bishop G7 so yeah
Bishop G7 does uh skure an exchange for
uh black I don't know uh first instinct
is I I'm not feeling that F7 F5 was the
right choice but let's see how the game
did un old F5 was played and finally we
do get an imbalance but this imbalance
this majority I actually rather like for
white only because this pass Pawn is so
dangerous and furthermore uh Black's
majority on the queen sight is actually
protecting his King so it's not a
majority that you want to advance and
now white also has this easy play B4 A4
B5 which is exactly what got
did so I wonder what the problem was I
suppose that after takes on D4 there was
a line he really didn't like because I
think he would have preferred uh to take
that PA himself rather than allow white
to end up taking on E5 exactly and
getting into this position where the
problem with this Pawn on B6 is that you
always have this constant back rank
Checkmate fear right this Pawn on B6 is
uh a snake uh close to your king and
um it it it means that you always have
to be fearful of some type of tactic uh
that that will like for example this is
a kind of position where you could play
a queen C4 takes E6 and thanks to a back
rank Checkmate you know you would win
the game so definitely G is looking good
at this point now they do say that the
Knight on E6 is a is a great blockader
so that's one thing that Sergey has
going for him mhm but this is but I like
those major pieces of white I mean being
able to play the move Rook D6 is so huge
right that that is huge because and so
let's let's take a look why is he able
to play this
move twice exactly the problem is if we
take the pawn um from Black's
perspective this move Queen a F6 is
simply monstrous pin City H right first
of all the Knight is pinned to the queen
secondly again that back rank mating
problem the Knight has pinned to The
Rook in the meanwhile seven is on the
menu right Queen F7 Queen takes H6 give
we really want to get that Knight into
the game as well so Queen takes F5 uh
the whole black uh kingside structure is
collapsing and conversely just as you
said um uh Jen uh you really can't live
with the Rook on D6 and if you do take
the Rook with Rook takes D6 and then try
to play something like Queen F7 not to
allow the queen to F6 you were
mentioning how you would like to get
your knight into into play well guess
what you can get your knight into play
with a Tempo and that pawn is coming
down to D7 I think that God is looking
really really good in this specific
position and I'm sure Sergey is seeing
these very same variations and saying oh
my God how am I going to deal with this
this is really really uh bad news yeah
the tactics here are really looking up
for got to kamsky and uh I think you
know mgy might have must have missed
something in some variation because
there's no way he would have willingly
gone for this strategically I think he
you know chess is always that
combination of strategy and tactic so
maybe Rook D6 he missed how powerful
Queen F6 was at the end of the variation
or maybe he thought he could take on D4
something like that possibly but I
really do think it was an error of
judgment I I think that when he played
that move F5 he anticipated that he
would get his Knight to E6 where he was
really really safe and solid and then
came this Rook D6 like a ton of bricks
well yeah that's hard to hard to see so
far in advance well yeah but it's looks
like you have that square covered yeah
but it's one of those things that you
could you know when you're on the other
side of the board it's the most natural
move in the in the world to play the
move Rook D6 when you're defending it's
like maybe you mentally uh you've got
your bias you you you tune that move out
but really I think the error of judgment
was that these majorities this past Eve
pwn versus the majority on the queen
side very very favorable for white bad
decision by Sergey he's suffering now
and this is exciting our top rated um
player and our defending Champion maybe
getting back into the thick of things
now we've mentioned that today is a rest
day for the US Women's Championship
players are doing all sorts of different
things some of them can't get enough of
jazz and in fact we do have one of our
competitors coming off of her first win
here at the US Women's Championship
Alysa
is with Grandmaster
Ashley indeed we managed to rope Alyssa
to come in and join us on the show
actually she wanted to first of all
welcome Melissa okay thanks again for
having me you won yesterday so it must
have felt pretty good uh what have you
done in the last 24 hours yeah
unfortunately I didn't have too much
time to celebrate even though we have a
rest day today that's a bit of a
misnomer because that actually means
that even though we're not playing we
have a lot of more time to get preing
and that creates a sense of urgency
because you don't know how much time
your opponent is spending preparing for
you so that's pretty much what I've been
doing you've been spending the whole day
so you get a rest day you're not going
out enjoying the sun you you come here
to watch the games of the US
Championship I did I finally got a
chance to catch the broadcast and the
commentary you know when I'm playing I
don't really see what's going on so it's
cool to come to the club and see
everything that goes on behind the
scenes here I will forgive you for that
then so uh so far you have a Point um
you've been watching the men's games
though which game has caught your eye
well the one that I can relate to the
most is the schan between molner and Gua
because I'm an E4 and an E4 E5 player um
it's a very interesting matchup it's a
clash between two very creative players
so I expected some fireworks early on in
the game but um it seemed to have
fizzled out a bit but it is definitely
exciting to watch and I'm rooting for
mag here I'm rooting for the other wild
card really why why are you rooting for
him just because he's a wild card well I
mean he's a wild card for a reason right
I mean he plays exciting chess I've
played him in tournaments a few times so
I'm familiar with his more
unconventional style I do judging for
the game of the um year contest for the
US chess league and his games always
come up so yeah yeah he does have a wild
style about him he like loves to attack
any other players in the championship
that you've played uh give us a little
tidbit on their
style um I've played play Robson before
Lenderman shankland um have a pretty
decent score against the field actually
I've drawn Mack a few times I drew
Shanklin the one time I played him I
played B6 against him on move one after
E4 so that yeah the Owens defense reel
it out yeah I don't think we'll be
seeing any of the Owens defense in
either of the Championships this year um
but yeah I had a pretty good game
against um Robson a few years ago and
from what I know about him he's a very
resourceful player he puts pressure on
his opponent at just the right moment
and I was looking at his game earlier
against Lenderman where he did a very
interesting exchange sacrifice I thought
it would work out positionally in his
favor but then I think may have been a
mistake to take the pawn earlier on in
the game and he lost control indeed his
position does not look great here well
you do have a rest a today but you have
a big game tomorrow against the youngest
player in the field she doesn't have
many games in the database how could you
prepare for for ashria asan who's really
the talk of the Women's Championship
right now absolutely she has barely any
games in the database but it it's not
too long ago that I was in her position
as a young upand cominging player and I
remember that I tended to do the best
when other people used to underestimate
me so I'm not going to make that mistake
I'm taking her as seriously as I am any
other player and you know I I don't want
to give too much away but there's not
much that I can give away because you
know there's there's not much that I can
do to prepare for her concretely but
it's more about getting positions that
I'm comfortable in and what I can count
on is having my experience show and
experience a veteran at 22 Well I this
is my sixth US Women's Championship
fifth time being in St Louis so yeah I
mean I'm I'm only 22 so I still feel
young but then you see this new
generation of players rising up yeah she
says she still feels young it's it's sad
to to hear at 22 you're you're a babe uh
a question when you see a young player
like this playing the way she's playing
I mean she's had fascinating endings
actually both of her endings have been
the the fod for for Twitter and the
internet because it's they've been
really attractive endings you can but
but sort of root for her although you
can't obviously because you you need to
win your game against her but she's
really been playing some fine
interesting chess yeah well I always
like to root for the underdog so of
course in her other matchups you know
I'm rooting for her and I can see that
she's definitely a
fighter indeed and that's that's what it
takes to win of these championships well
thank you so much for joining us Alyssa
and good luck in the rest of the
championship okay thanks very much
Alyssa mahina uh here with us giving her
insights on her day off from the women's
championships but we'll need to get back
to battle tomorrow back to you
guys and I know exactly what she's
talking about too when you get those
free days and you think oh it's so
wonderful now I don't have to play and
the next thing you know you're either
watching around or you're spending so
much time preparing you said my God my
free day wasn't really free I spent my
whole time training uh myself and uh you
don't store up your energy I like the
approach by Grandmaster Walter Brown and
I found his approach um something I
could never replicate he said to me and
I really recall his words very vividly
he said you shouldn't be preparing at
the tournament mhm should be prepared
before the tournament play tennis go
swimming play pingpong watch TV don't
prepare at the tournament but not
everyone can do that exactly I could
never do that I mean great words of
advice from a six-time US chess champion
prepare before the tournament not at the
tournament and yet when I'm at the
tournament I just feel like gosh I play
I got to Camp ski tomorrow I've got to
prepare and I fall into the Trap of
sometimes spending too much time
preparing my games indeed yeah so how to
how to deal with the rest I think that
strategy might make most sense at the
beginning of the tournament you know and
then later people might have to tweak
their opening strategies based on the
situation of the tournament exactly and
also based on what their opponents have
played so right maybe the ideal is try
to just focus on relaxing for the first
three days and then be realistic that
towards the end of the tournament I mean
I read an interview with karnick W where
he said he's preparing up to the last
minute of the game right and and that's
also around Robin so if Vladimir cranic
says it then you figure this is an issue
that goes all the way down the line that
you know even if ideally they would be
relaxing most players just can't help
themselves right and I remember Gary
Kasparov Victor kchoi preparing
literally to the last minutes of the
game one guy actually was very
interesting was get was anat karp off he
didn't necessarily like preparing till
the last minute on the game uh quite
often hours before play he would just
like to play Blitz and warm up and keep
uh sharp uh mind but but not necessarily
studying that's exactly the opposite of
what most he wanted relaxed tell most
people tell kids that they should not
play Blitz during a
tournament well one you know it's so
exciting these chess championships in St
Louis we've got the singfield cup coming
up um some other exciting chess news
we've got the millionaire chess open
that's good for chess in America and
it's in Las Vegas actually the US Chess
Federation hosts a tournament in Vegas
every year as well the national and one
of the great things about Chess in Las
Vegas is that in addition to playing
chess you can play poker I love poker
and fact I'm working with poker stars
and some initiatives to uh promote chess
and poker together all right they've
actually been the sponsor um Alysa
mentioned that she was the uh one of the
judges for the best game for the US
chess league and right it's interesting
not everybody knows but Poker Stars has
been the sponsor of the US chess league
for nine years fabulous I didn't know
that that's wonderful indeed yeah great
and we've got a little bit more on the
millionaire chess open some details and
right after that we'll bring another of
our star players here for you with an
interview with Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley who is the creator of the
millionaire chess
open welcome to the world of The
Surreal you take the blue pawn and
return to the comfortable world of Chess
tournaments as you know
you take the red Pond and I'll show you
a chess event Beyond Your Wildest
imagination
this he hey and we have uh one of our
young Grandmasters with Maurice Ashley
Daniel
nitzki Thanks Jen with Grandmaster
Daniel nitzki after a draw with last
year's runner up Alejandro Ramirez first
of all welcome to the show thanks so you
played some unusual chess in the opening
of the game we were remarking on this
line when you play the move A3 and queen
F3 it was quite a funky sequence of
moves is that something that's new or
you specially prepared I think it's
Theory I mean I've seen that before this
idea with A3 to stop night B4 and could
have three and I thought I got a good
position so you actually looked like you
had a very nice position out the opening
what what happened after that okay I I'm
looking at Houdini's assessment here I
think maybe I played well and I just
okay I thought this position was uh with
the queen and Rook versus queen and Rook
I just thought that was drawn but
perhaps I could have found chances or
somewhere earlier in the middle game
I'll have to take a look did you feel
disappointed did you did you feel like
you had an edge throughout abely
something was there yeah I think had an
advantage I sort of Let It Go um
multiple time so yeah pretty
disappointing but you know when you were
sitting at the board that feeling came
over you and you decided that you didn't
want to continue this position was
saying you still have some chances to
fight yeah no I played H4 which I think
is logical but it's wrong because he it
gives him a chance to consolidate I
didn't realize that I actually have an
initiative here like Queen F4 and okay
it's still probably objectively drawn
but uh I could have probably found more
chances here indeed did yesterday's game
maybe affect you in this game or how do
you manage your emotions after a loss in
the championship well I felt more
aggressive today I wanted to play for a
win obviously and not sort of collapse
and and kind of let the tournament go um
and I think I I did pretty well out of
the opening but again a little
disappointing that I didn't at least um
you know give him more of a fight but
you know it is what it is I guess and
who do you play tomorrow uh Ray Robson
so you get Ray Ray is having a very
tough time of it right now yeah he is I
yeah I think he's losing so does that
does that help your mindset do you feel
better that your opponent's having a
tough result before uh you get to play
them uh not really and I just play the
best moves I don't I try not to pay
attention to what kind of tournament my
opponent is having because obviously at
this level you can play an individual
game at a very high level so indeed
finally uh your mom was here on the show
earlier we got her to interview she was
was chatting about uh today what are you
doing for Mother's day uh I don't know
not not too much I guess better get some
flowers young man
okay yeah it's a tournament so
understood I'm sure I'm sure a win or a
draw is probably more of a gift for her
yeah well thanks for joining us on the
show and we wish you the best in the
rest of the tournament appreciate
Grandmaster Daniel nitzky the youngest
competitor in the men's competition
drawing today and uh get some flowers
for you
back to you Jen yet I have an idea for
her Mother's Day gift actually the
producers brought some sushi for Maurice
grab it it's right there on the
fridge Lena will love the sushi right
well I that was interesting what
Daniel's saying that he didn't re
doesn't really pay too much attention to
how his opponent played um and I take
just the opposite view if I really
really like it when I playing an
opponent who who just lost in the
previous round I take the attitude if my
opponent's drowning throw him an anvil
you know like jump on you seem so mild
mannered yeah but the killer comes out
at the chessboard right right we were
talking about that earlier the opposite
how somebody like Ray Robson has this
really aggressive chest style and yet is
so sweet in person right soft another
one definitely but you see at their
board they go for your lungs boy they're
they're tough tough competitors so I
take the attitude if my competitor is
having a hard time you know keep piling
on the pressure
race struggling to save this
position but I think we need to do a
break Jen what do you say yeah I think
uh we I think we got another result in
believe the csky game might be over as
well so yeah why don't we find out
what's going on in all of these games if
we can uh oh yes I do I see aronburg and
gakamsky both getting up in the board so
and it looks like uh I would imagine
that would be a draw cuz I don't think G
could have won so quickly do you think
he could have won so quickly I do I
think G had I think he had just a a
dominant position we'll find out and
perhaps there was a blender in time
control that just sealed the
deal I think it was just a big position
seriously I think that that point after
Rook D6 I mean I think that was the
Splat that was the killer kind of move
and I didn't see uh I think Sergey
played
H5 but uh after got Domin on the defile
it was really too much I think that that
got has scored his first victory in this
us
Championship oh and here it is and this
is the final position um and you are
absolutely right uh this just looks like
uh well this was the position
analysis wow this couldn't be the
position because that was what we looked
at and it was just it was his dead meet
yeah yeah let's try to let's try to get
some of these uh games up after we take
a quick break
okay be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the World Chess Hall of Fame
in St Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history called and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and worldclass art play
together the World Chess Hall of Fame
mind art
experience
hi I'm Lindsay part of the admissions
team here at Paul Mitchel the school St
Louis our campus is located on Maryland
Plaza right here in the gorgeous Central
West
End I chose Paul Mitchell the School St
Louis because I visited other schools
and when I was at them I just felt like
the energy level wasn't the same it
wasn't as elevated as it is
here when I came here it just felt right
everybody looked great everybody had
such a great attitude the facility was
really clean and just so much more
advanced technology can truly enhance
your
education when we brought in Chromebooks
and we started using the smart TVs we
really tapped into the 21st century
learner being a student of pal mitell is
great because the learning leaders
they're there to guide you in the right
direction they give you the opportunity
to make decisions on your own they
accept you for who you are and they're
always welcome and honest and
open we have encouraged our guests to to
host Google reviews so far to date have
over 100 reviews with an average rating
of 4.5
stars i' like that this isn't just for
hair and beauty but it's also a business
college you can learn hair you can brush
it you can tease it you can learn all of
that but to do business that's something
that really takes a whole different
level of
Education whether we're in the classroom
our at the color bar we're always having
a great time at Paul Mitchell the School
St
Louis being a student at Paul Mitchell
gives you a lot of opportunity for when
you're ready to get out into the real
world thank you for taking a sneak peek
of our campus and we can't wait for you
to come and see what a palal education
can do for
you
hey guys welcome back to the St Louis
chess club and the 2014 US Chess
Championship we've got defending
Champion gamsky with Maurice Ashley to
talk about the finish of his game
against Sergey
arberg indeed a four-time champion
gakamsky having won his first game of
the championship for first of all thanks
and welcome to the show thank you marce
got uh you you hadn't won a game yet
after three rounds you mentioned that
that had never happened to you before at
the championship is this the strongest
Championship you've ever played in well
without nakamuro I can't really say this
is the strongest Championship but it is
very strong um we have a lot of
underrated players who some were not
competing for years maybe and um some
players who haden't had a chance to
compete so you know they're very strong
but just it doesn't show on the r
indeed an all GM field as a matter of
fact was is the first time we've had
that at the US Championship well we
didn't get a chance to see the finish of
your game it looked like uh the game was
somewhat even in the beginning of the
game but then you slowly outplayed him
and then you got to this really nice
position take us through the finish here
as to how you won the
game okay so in this position I thought
that white is close to winning because
um I have very strong outpost on D6 and
Black's King is really boxed in uh
creating a lot of mating so this is very
unpleasant for black so black played
here
F4 I4 okay and then I played Queen
C4 with the idea of taking on A6 with
the queen um trying to get the black
queen away from protecting d8 Square so
black so so little let's just show that
um would you press new variation for me
please and you were planning to do this
sacrifice right exactly because if black
takes and rook d8 and white recaptures
the material indeed winning a piece cuz
he has to block and you just get an
extra Knight here okay so instead of
that uh black play Queen C4 King C8
trying to you know move his pieces
closer together and I had to take on F4
mhm BL has to take and Rook one
D5 and um I think basically the position
is lost because there just too many
threats black blundered the pawn on C5
with Queen
F7 and after Rook C5
you know black cannot recapture The Rook
because of hanging Queen so nasty pin on
that diagonal King B8 was played and
then Rook
C7 again following the tying up of the
material and black he resigned because
as you just explained queen6 is uh
losing to to Queen D5 and if black takes
Rook then Rook d8
made and he gets made it a vicious uh
finish well so you've got your win in
your pocket uh it's four rounds so far
your one of your main Rivals onishchuk
also won and gev had won his game so you
you guys at the top are definitely
chasing your leader who is surprisingly
Alexander Lenderman how do you feel
about the fact that he's currently in
the lead clear lead in the tournament
well I'm not surprised I think that was
actually long overdue because
Alexander has been playing in many
International tournaments and every game
we played was a major major struggles
some even fantastic draws and I always
felt that um he should be somewhere on
top but he didn't had a chance to play
in many International tournaments maybe
for the last two years only and now he
has a chance to shine and to show his
true worth so it's nice to see him play
well fantastic so who do you get
tomorrow uh have you thought about it
I'm not sure you're not sure okay well
we wish you the best congratulations on
your win we wish you the best in the
rest of the tournament thank you our
reigning Champion the four-time champion
Grandmaster gakamsky showing his
strength here in this fourth round of
the US Championship back to you Jen Nas
that is what I would describe as power
chess in the last 10 15 moves of God's
game because he really played incredibly
accurately uh to finish the game and a
very nice and important victory for our
us Championship us defending US champion
he needs a little confidence to get some
wind in his sales in order to keep Pace
with Alexander Lenderman who by the way
has got a great position against Ray
Robson I have so a bit of a
transformation here he's no longer up in
exchange but now he's up uh two very
promising bonds and get those doggies
rolling what I've seen is when we had
left it it was a a pretty nice tactical
sequence uh we were back here with this
move Rook C7 had been White's last move
and black
is uh it's not black is not able to uh
stop this Rook captures H6 check type of
uh threat so G5 was played Rook takes H6
King came to G7 attacking The Rook as
well as the bishop a little bit of a
surprise for me I must say uh G3 G4
again a very tactical solution to the
situation I felt that this ending after
Rook A6 uh The Rook versus the two
pieces but the problem is is white has
many Pawns in the
position uh passers on the on the queen
side passer in the center and a
potential passer over here that was
not uh Alex's Choice what he did instead
is he went for G4 very tactical solution
takes takes Ray doing his best to try to
cause white problem act problems
activated his Rook trying to come to
down to D2 but but look at this check
King Bishop Rook now this key move Rook
E6 if white can push this Knight out of
the center then this Pawn on E3 can get
rolling and that's exactly what happened
Knight drop back and look at those pawns
go check and this is the last position I
saw the players have made moves but it
seems to me that these two pawns are
monsters and
F7 E6 Rook E8 and it's coronation time
that's what I'm seeing I think our
tournament leader Alex Lenderman at plus
two two and a half from three is going
to go to plus three I mean they just
made move 40 so I wonder if this game's
going to last much longer I mean F7
rookie 8 just looks devastating exactly
so let's see what and that did happen it
looks like F7 occurred on the board Okay
so we got this position and Ray doing
his best to stay in the game played
Knight E3 F7 as you mentioned check and
Rook comes back uh pay attention there
is the old thread of Czech Maiden one
and H3 making more than 20 push-ups
foring that right H3 making lift for the
king and after H3 do we have a move I
don't really see how on Earth Ray is
stopping E5 E6 and Rook down and uh
playing f8 equals queen or even just
rate immediately it's just uh oh you
don't even need to protect it thanks to
the bishop on B3 agreed yeah this looks
uh like we're going to probably see a
resignation rather soon right looks
hopeless to me as
well great well Alexander Lenderman
three and a half out of four that's a
big score in the US Championship it is
huge and especially in the in a
championship we've been talking about is
that on paper at least one of the most
balanced Fields we've ever seen in all
grandm field one of the strongest
tournaments Maybe by rating both uh onuk
and G were both quick to say well we are
missing Hikaru so if we took out one
player put it in hikaro I'm absolutely
convinced that would have been the
strongest tournament on record that's
right and I like what oneruk said the
most solid the most solid yes us just
from a very solid player himself he
should know and we have something from
Maurice
Ashley indeed without Hikaru Nakamura
the number one player in the country one
of the top 10 players in the world you
really feel like the tournament has lost
some of his shine however with so many
Grand Masters in fact an Allstar field
of grand Masters you realize that you
still have an incredibly powerful
tournament now speaking of Lenderman he
clearly is winning this position this is
just just a bust but I've seen him take
the lead in a lot of tournaments before
he has the tendency to start off very
very strong but then get tripped up
later in the competition so we will have
to ask him that when he comes down here
I don't want to put any negative
thoughts in his mind but it's his track
record it's been hiso to take a lead
early even in Monster competitions and
end up tripping later at the end that's
kind of losing his Edge we'll find out
what he has to say about that and how
he's going to turn that around here at
these US championships back to you
guys good point uh it's not all it's not
all about a fast start but a good finish
and that's crucial shall we take a look
at some of the other games going on yeah
what do we have left so it looks like
lerman's about to seal the deal csk's
won csky and owners have both won their
game so um it sounds like I was right
about the men taking over for the women
in terms of decisive games right we're
up to about three out of four four now
yes we've seen a a few decisive games in
the first three rounds but this the
fourth round things definitely heating
up I've just brought in the game between
mullner and team Mor garv uh garv going
in today's round with a score of plus
one so he was just trailing uh Lenderman
by a half a point and for him to keep
Pace he's going to need to win today's
game uh this is the current position I'm
just to uh go back a few mooves to see
what the history of the play has been up
to this point when Alyssa came for her
interview on her rest day of the women's
she said that this game intrigued her
the the creativity of both players yes
and she's absolutely right um this is a
game uh I love these battles of ideas uh
over here on the queen side we see this
very nice Knight which is entrenched on
the B3 Square uh keeping this Pawn on B2
which which means that this Rook on B1
is playing a very passive role as black
could always swing a knight over here to
A4 what though you have no uh Pawn
breakthroughs or work lines right this
uh this game you still only traded one
pair of Pawns oh exactly so uh what
teore is going to have to do to win this
game is to open up the position a bit
and we're about to see exactly how he's
going going to go about threat on uh on
B2 and B3 is not playable because of
Knight takes C3 check that's a big check
but it it certainly going to come up
soon enough so Knight C5 was played Rook
D1 King B7 and here we see seeing black
just reorganize his pieces and finally a
move that I've been expecting for some
time is um t- More's last move what tore
needs to do is to get his Center Pawn
rolling so I'm anticipating something
like C7 C6 D5 and doubling Rooks on the
dile so a Prelude to that was Rook to d8
and let me make sure I'm up to date with
the players well we got a bishop G5 in
so uh Bish B5 Rook D7 has been so we
won't be able to double Rook so easily
but now the B2 Pawn is more tender again
mhm at the moment it's adequately
defended if I'm in Max shoes here I'm a
little bit worried that when this Pawn
comes to D5 my king might find itself
suddenly um getting all kinds of
attention by Black's pieces so if I were
in white shoes I would probably want to
come back with the move King e retreat
with the move King E2 to D1 with the
idea of playing King to C2 where I feel
the king is a little bit safer on the
flank rather than the center as well as
to bolster this Pawn on B2 at the moment
I still feel that black is has an edge
but it's going to take some great
technique to convert it into a material
Edge I wonder about some sacrificial
ideas here just to play around so if we
play D5 here sure let's have some fun
why not D5 well I'll take it so I'll
give you your chance to do some sacrif
sacrificing Rook takes D5 Jen what and
King has to come up because the Knight
was hanging and now you want to do some
SA ricing well I was thinking about a
different variation but I I think we can
also think about were you thinking about
work takes D3 here I I didn't I didn't
see the we can't we can't really grab on
B2 because just King C2 Forks the Knight
so right it's a double attack if I could
win a pawn that would be nice but MH you
you want a pawn to go for that to go I
was think about a similar line where I
could play Rook F2 like if you didn't
take on D5 and let me take on e4 I was
thinking then maybe Rook D3 King D3 Rook
F2 would be interesting right so you
want to get get in some kind of E4 break
or I thought I for some reason I didn't
think you were going to take on D5
because it allows me for instance maybe
after Rook D5 King C2 we could try King
D7 just Rook
D7 the doubling Rooks on the dile that's
that's why I thought maybe you weren't
going to go this way right which is the
the type of thing that I wanted to do a
moment you night before yeah that well
night before Rook D2 that's a that's a
pretty Checkmate let's show our viewers
that Checkmate that's a good one that is
a very very very sweet well if I take
then you you get to M me up a rook yes
down a rook down a rook so that's a
sweet so instead you would have to well
after Rook D2 Bishop D2 Rook D2 is is
all is it all over though yes it yeah
because if you go the other way it's
bait right but I was thinking that white
might instead of capturing the Knight
play a move like Rook D1 and still I'm
not convinced that uh black has enough
in this position uh
to night W but but uh check doesn't seem
like it's that powerful but definitely
the pressure play Rook A1 Rook D3 and
then maybe some consolidate
yeah okay so um let's just see what
moves were're played by way possible
that's why I was thinking that maybe
after takes on D5 instead of Rook takes
D5 allowing for these possibility of
double the Rooks on the dile I thought
that you were maybe just going to let me
take on e4 so you
you yeah and then you had wanted a
sacrifice like this yeah and then I was
considering Rook takes D3 King D3 um
Rook F2 because Knight B2 King C2 right
right so here and and now we have
some so like
two wonderful checkmates this is one the
king can't go to E3 thank to this Knight
so that's a lovely Checkmate and this is
the second one oh no that's that's not I
was going to play Rook D2 uh we yeah the
bishop there and Knight B2 is not meat
because the E3 Pawn square is opened up
again but still this looks really
powerful I mean how many do we need
night C5 was good enough and then the B2
Pawn also under under Fire that was why
I didn't want to okay let the Rook on F7
into the game and that was why against
the move D5 I was trying to keep that
that f file close don't want to see
after Rook D5 King C2 Rook D7 Rook D1 we
still didn't find anything for black huh
but nothing
convincing I don't see a
convincing
um I in all seriousness I was looking at
night one check but I guess you you just
uh you just you just take it and then
after Rook takes D3 you just have uh at
least I at least you can't play Rook D1
to trade everything CU B2 is hanging at
the end exactly so that's kind of cool
but but this bishop is doing such great
defensive work I'm not oops my diagonal
not have much we kind of wanted that
night on B3 yeah so like maybe something
like A4 and I think white could be just
fine or perhaps just questioning are you
really planning on sacrificing thech
putting the question to you I mean to
say with a move like Rook e one not an
easy uh decision I can I can make an
argument I see you're trying to say
rooky wants a good move because it gives
you some counterplay for instance in the
line Rook D2 check Bishop D2 Rook takes
D2 now after something like King C1 Rook
B2 you might be able to play a move like
Rook E5 precisely um kind of
highlighting that that the Knight is
overloaded he you can't take the Rook
without losing The Rook here but even
this yeah it's like pretty messy because
Rook takes G2 I guess Rook back to youan
Rook takes G2 say Rook G5 just to stop
this check G yeah and offering a trade
of Rooks uh but again it's uh it's
promising for garv but no guarantees of
Victory you have some really exciting
lines here though we got we got one of
these mate in the end game positions
right right all the fun mates in the end
game well one of the one of the things I
must say I really admire about teore um
somehow he's a Head Hunter and he's able
to weave
some really beautiful checkmates out of
conjure up these mating Nets in
positions
where you you say wow where did that
come from so he's remarkably original in
head hunting and yet also as we're
seeing today he can play the position
very slowly and just he had this better
structure that uh came right out of the
opening and he's still the player with
the advantage and Mac uh once more is
facing a difficult
defense what other games do we have we
just have two games going on just the uh
just uh Ray game as well as Lenderman
Robson Lenderman uh I mean Robson rather
hasn't resigned yet he has played a move
he played
G4 so he thought that he still had
something to kind of keep the pressure
on okay I am not getting that game up on
my screen so the moment I can't
um bring it up well if you recall in
that position he ended up playing
G4 G so yeah you want to try refreshing
the board yeah
sure okay I'm sorry I do apologize but I
don't have an internet connection we we
do see them up here um the board and it
looks like Alexander man is trying to
figure out what to do after this move G4
geez I don't imagine it's going to give
enough a play for Robson though well you
definitely simply got to take it you got
to take yeah you don't want to let him
play G2 do you well let now we're
getting a little closeup on the board so
that's nice so yeah after takes on G4 KN
G4 well then we'll go Rook E8 well let's
bring Maurice in here and see what uh
what the computer uh is how the computer
is
evaluating uh Whit's uh chances a
victory
mauce uh the computer has decided to go
on vacation because this game is not
worth its attention anymore it's over
this is done this is crushed City uh the
move H3 was played G4 is just tossing a
pawn uh into the shark's mouth uh he
could just take it there's nothing
that's going to happen uh after this
move later he might be able to pull off
some check by capturing the pawn but the
problem of Rook to E8 is in the threat
is on threat in this position and what
can he do he can maybe try to bring his
King back but E6 is going to happen
there's just nothing to do here this is
a dominant position slowly but surely
it's going to happen that this King will
lead the enter because these pieces will
have to back up to try to stop these
pawns and when that happens it's just
going to be a matter of time or the
pawns are just going to Queen so this
game is really indeed over Lenderman
just has to be careful mil the advantage
home and he'll be our sole leader a full
point ahead of the rest of the field
Robson by the way had two points coming
to this round so this has got to be a
bad situation for him uh it looks as
though a move indeed was played after H
takes G4 uh the pawn was snapped off so
Robson slowly running out of Pawns on
his chess board and by the way look at
that clock over there 14 minutes left uh
you know Robson loves to get into time
pressure was a bad deal to get into time
pressure when you're at the moment two
pawns down and two pass pawns down on
top of it so this game this game is
over well it sure looks to me like uh
the the last move by Ray G4 was just
hoping I don't know exactly what he was
hoping that maybe he could go to G3 but
obviously H takes G4 just cries to be
played once that move is played I don't
really see anything uh like mace saying
that would justify playing
resigned actually I think he's about to
resign he doesn't have a game face on
anymore you see that no he the he he
knows that some something went wrong
uh I don't think his exchange sacrifice
was bad in fact I thought it was quite
inventive it was just this followup uh
trading the C5 Pawn for the D5 Pawn that
really uh looked lame to me and I'm sure
he has regrets himself about that
decision yeah sure and it does look like
we've it is his move
again after takes on G4 and uh perhaps
Ray
is considering the resignation
now and uh let's go over to
Maurice indeed that position you talked
about yes is so fascinating it's deeply
instructive this business of exchange
sacrifices particularly what it is that
you captured in this position Rook takes
on E3 looks like it just comes
completely out of blue and after F takes
on E3 the move Knight to B4 and Black's
pieces are making incursions on the
white position you can see that this is
a great knight this bishop is fantastic
on this diagonal this bishop also has
some power and in this position the move
Knight to E4 was played right now is
where he made his mistake when you are
ahead but when you have sacrificed an
exchange if you especially if you've
done it for a bishop a dark you want to
know the color of the bishop in this
case it was a dark Square bishop and the
only pieces that can control the dark
squares to fight back against this piece
are these guys the knights cuz this
light Square Bishop cannot this piece is
the only guy that can fight back or this
guy so get a chance to get rid of the
knights snap him off this is what he did
not do this was his best move here so
after this capture which color you
attacking on the dark squares KN to A4
highly unusual but now you see that
whites pieces can't easily fight back
against the dark Square attack which is
where the capture the sacrifice on E3
took place so you have if you had
sacrificed for a light squared Bishop it
would have been the opposite but